ladies and gentlemen today I want to
talk to you about how to lose 1 billion
dollars no that's not clickbait in the
last video if you remember I showed you
guys how this guy right here made 207
million dollars by running a Ponzi
scheme and I asked you what would happen
if that guy was a little more clever a
little more polished was a little bit
smoother well today we find out
welcome to season
[Music]
[Music]
guys future that is a weird crossbreed
between a social network a multi-level
marketing scheme as well as a Ponzi
scheme
now it was extremely convoluted and the
first thing I want you guys to
understand is that overcomplicating a
Ponzi scheme is part of what makes it
successful because in order to
successfully fool people you have to
make it hard for them to understand what
you're really doing like have you ever
wondered if you've ever been involved in
a multi-level marketing scheme why
everything is so complicated why it's
all so convoluted why the downline
reward structure is so strange it's
because if you guys understood it you
would know to run away a successful scam
is never easy to understand and just
sort of penetrate the veil it's always
overly complicated and future net has
that down basic-level member $10 is gold
$50 exclusive $100 sapphire $500 I know
this is probably pretty complicated and
I do want you guys to understand it to
understand why this is a scam so in
essence this is running the same scam
that trafficmonsoon was running which is
selling ad packs now if you don't know
what ad packs are it's something that is
acknowledged by the SEC to be a scam
essentially if they tell you that you're
going to be clicking on ten ads a day
and if you buy these ad packs for like
$50 in a period of months you will share
in the revenue of the site and make more
money back than you put in
by watching ten advertisements daily you
participate in enterprises general
turnover and profit after watching 10
ads during subsequent 24 hours every 15
minutes you will receive your part of
income to your online account so you put
in a $50 you click on 10 ads a day you
make 55 or 60 dollars back that was the
main draw of future net and why so many
people joined they thought this is easy
money where it becomes a ponzi though is
that those advertising dollars that
future Nets kept saying they had just
were never there they were always paying
people with money that was put in by
other adpack users and the problem is is
when you're making money you always want
to put more money back in which is why I
call this Ponzi's can be a lure of this
Ponzi scheme the invisible money trap
because what happens is they disguise it
by paying you right
so initially everybody's winning that's
why these things blow up to be so big
because the bait is so good you are
making money at the beginning you know
you make the money you put money back in
you make money you put money back in and
that's always how it starts and it
always seems so beautiful wonderful and
there's an incredible amount of optimism
with these things especially name the
beginning because everyone's just
excited everyone's make money at the
start of it and you can see that in
their promos and their events are
lavished they're insane they're crazy
and they can afford such wild events
because they're making so much money and
most of the people they're paying out to
are just going and reinvesting that same
money back into the site that's why the
bait of Ponzi schemes is so good now
we're gonna talk a lot about victims in
the next episode of this show but for
now I just want to show you one story to
explain exactly how this trap works
the invisible money trap I have this
chat with a victim pulled up in front of
me where he's from a poor country I'm
gonna be blocking his name and he says I
lost ninety five hundred dollars how can
I get back my money he doesn't speak
English very well actually a lot of the
victims of these scams are overseas but
he says I how can I get back my money
and I asked him you know how he lost so
much money well it comes out that he
took out a bank loan for this and is now
stuck basically trying to pay back ten
thousand dollars of a bank loan and I
asked him why did you put in ten
thousand dollars and here was his
response he says he went in after his
friend invested and the person was
making money for six months no problem
with the company all was good then he
made his first transaction he's
skeptical he only puts in $1,000 that
was good so he's making money from the
site and you can just feel that
skepticism died away the excitement
builds up they're throwing all these
lavish events the two inventors who are
Polish guys they
look clean-cut right their names are
Stefan Morgenstern and Roman Zeeman and
the way they talk they're so charismatic
they're so they're so charming and so
this guy eventually he goes okay well
I'm making money from my thousand
dollars
let's go all-in so he takes out that
bank loan and ultimately well the thing
went belly up and that's what you find a
lot is people from foreign countries
going into debt for what they think is
going to be their golden ticket out of
their poverty which makes it so sad
because actually it becomes a way to
keep poor people poor right because they
can never rise the middle class if
you're constantly scamming them with
these things that are costing them
thousands of dollars but I don't want to
get ahead of myself I don't want to get
too much into the victim stories because
that's gonna be for another episode for
now we're talking about the architecture
of a great Ponzi scheme and I say great
only in terms of its success not in
terms of the ethics obviously this is
incredibly unethical I hope the people
who started this go to prison but I
think it's important to focus on what
made this so successful because when you
look at their events these are not small
hotel rooms full of people these are
arenas in their 2018 Macau ceremony the
thing is like a Justin Bieber concert or
something like that these guys are rock
stars and they are acting like it look
at this intro they're going to be
transforming the future and they're
going to help all of us ladies and
gentlemen Romani Jim young Stefan Morgan
stage I love her right off the bat it's
basically transformers I mean I read
seriously this is like the Autobots are
about to come in here
this is a little bit of a fortnight you
think before fort and I'd ever thought
to do the wormhole by the way I'm not
sure if that was a laugh from like the
Roman and Stefan
or if the person who ripped this on to
YouTube laughed while they saw that
because that wasn't me for the record
some of that's like Star Wars Planet of
the Apes soundtrack going on there
[Music]
I've just got to say that that's how to
make a hell of an entrance and the thing
is that's not even unique these people
had a whole cult following
they even had music videos made about
them
[Music]
fusion and they
we're changing people's laugh phone back
seriously
as we show the world what's going on at
a tight future net felt like a rocket
ship for people and it was constantly
rolling out new initiatives in order to
propel that optimism because even as
advertisers weren't coming into the site
like people were told they were future
net was busy launching new products like
futuro
a crypto coin that ultimately took a
nosedive along with the company they
were launching things like an AR video
game to collect said cryptocurrency use
everything you had to fight with your
opponent but remember they are extremely
dangerous and will fight back they were
running a foundation when they said they
were helping humanity and it was easy to
get swept away in all of this and forget
to think about the core business model
and how this thing would last forever
not to mention the celebrity
endorsements they got were pretty
spectacular they sponsored a Red Bull
Racing team they sponsored the Pope
actually scratched that part they lied
about getting sponsored by the Pope they
photoshopped their picture of their
company onto a Lamborghini that the Pope
was supposedly signing and ultimately
auctioning off Roman and Stefan were the
rulers of their own little world for a
small time but all good things must come
to an end and when they do what happens
what happened to Stefan Roman and what
happened to the millions of people who
were invested in future net because at
its peak future net had 3 million users
which if you assume that only a third of
them were invested and you assume that
well maybe they were invested at about
the same level that trafficmonsoon got
people in at this company was making
aliens and this is verified actually by
the direct selling industry who said
that at its height they were making over
a billion dollars a year in revenue this
company checked all the boxes in terms
of preying on people's greed preying on
people's desperation preying on people's
willingness to believe in lavish
lifestyle presentations like this and
when things come crashing down when this
illusion finally drops things are about
to get ugly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
[Music]